la parole est à notre collègue pierre
charon pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur président et merci pour
cette initiative nouvelle qui réunit
beaucoup d'amis monsieur président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur remise de
l'intérieur nous avons appris mardi 22
septembre par une indiscrétion du monde
une fois de plus l'existence d'une note
confidentielle madame hidalgo
réfléchissant aux catimini et une
réforme du statut de paris cette réforme
qui envisage un redécoupage des
arrondissements appel notamment un
projet de loi pour 2016
or nous sommes coutumiers de ces textes
pris dans l'urgence pour éviter
certaines déconvenues électorales et
pour préserver certaines équipes en
place souvenez vous des élections
municipales et départementales dont les
modes de scrutin avait été réformée en
2013 leur modification n'a pas empêché
l'arroseur d'être arrosé par des vagues
bleues de 2014 et 2015 si madame hidalgo
réfléchit à une telle organisation
c'est parce que 2020 en ligne de mire
déjà pour 2016 année de mise en place du
grand paris un amendement déposé en
deuxième lecture par le gouvernement
lors du projet là la nôtre avait pour
but d'exclure une élue parisienne du
conseil de la métropole il a
heureusement été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel dont je salue la sagesse
depuis deux ans nous assistons sans
cesse à les tentatives désespérées pour
corriger les réactions d'un corps
électoral
de plus en plus hostile ce ne sont pas
les binômes départementaux démesurée ni
les régions pléthorique forçant le
mariage de la carpe et du lapin qui
empêcheront l'inéluctable al'approche
d'élections régionales probablement
catastrophique pour vous il se murmure
que la proportionnelle serait envisagée
pour les élections législatives rapport
bartolone winoc monsieur le ministre
vous qui avez un certain crédit dans
cette es mythique grâce à votre sens des
dialogues
pouvez-vous nous rassure et rassurer la
représentation nationale et notamment le
sénat qu'il n'y aura pas à nouveau de
tripatouillage électoral de tour de
passe passe à l'occasion des prochaines
élections législatives et sénatoriales
afin de laisser après votre passage une
terre brûlée pour la démocratie
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve
monsieur le sénateur pierre charon poser
une question concernant une proposition
formulée par madame et hidalgo maire de
paris cette proposition elle repose sur
quatre idées simples une première idée
qui est celle de la fusion entre la
commune de paris et le département dans
un objectif de simplification de
modernisation cela correspond à ce que
sont les objectifs de rationalisation et
de modernisation de notre tissu local
porté par le gouvernement mais bien
entendu une telle idée appel d expertise
d analyse des études et comme vous
l'appelez de vos voeux je suis certain
que c'est également le souhait de madame
le maire de paris une telle analyse aura
vocation à faire l'objet d'un large
débat
voilà pour le premier sujet le deuxième
sujet repose sur une refonte ou des
modifications apportées à la carte des
arrondissements je comprends que vous
inquiétez que cette disposition pu avoir
des conséquences électorales mais de
toutes les façons pour des raisons qui
tiennent aux droits monsieur le sénateur
cette modification ne pourrait pas
intervenir avant 2020 elle ne pourrait
donc pas à voir les conséquences
électorales que vous indiquez et comme
vous avez l'air très sûr des résultats
des élections à venir vous ne pourriez
quand bénéficier cela devrait vous
satisfaire totalement troisième point
madame hidalgo propose qu'il y ait une
nouvelle répartition des compétences
entre l'état et la ville de paris dans
un certain nombre de domaines sur
lesquels la ville de paris veut affirmer
des prérogatives parce qu'elle a des
politiques publiques c'est le cas
notamment en matière d'environnement et
c'est le cas aussi sur un sujet dont je
sais qui vous tient particulièrement à
coeur qui est la question de la sécurité
pour ce qui concerne la question de la
sécurité j'ai indiqué à anne hidalgo que
j'étais tout à fait prêt à étudier avec
elle les propositions qu'elle faisait
qu'elle est dans la bonne direction
et bien entendu sur ce sujet là dans la
plus grande transparence je rendrai
compte de l'état de ses réflexions à la
représentation nationale
merci monsieur le minet